[Music]
hello everyone and welcome
i'm filippo and i work on the go team at
google it's the team that maintains the
go programming language
and today i'm joined by three of my
colleagues to answer questions collected
both before
this show and during the live ama
if you registered for the event and
reserved
your spot you'll see a q a button on the
right hand side of the video
so please do follow up on our answers
with questions
and we'll try to pick where we can
now myself i'm the lead of the security
team
and the security team is in charge of
making sure that go is a tool to build
secure applications
so not just making sure that go is
secure itself which is part of our job
but also making sure that you can use go
securely and safely to build
uh secure applications yourself and keep
your
your application safe hi
i'm katie i actually work over with uh
felipa on the go security team
over in new york city i came to the
security team after being a tech lead of
the go module mirror and checksum
database
which are tools that can help you
download go source code in a way that's
a lot more secure and a lot more
reliable
nowadays i've been working on adding
native fuzzing to go with my team
and that's a form of automated testing
that can help find edge case bugs
that you your unit tests might miss
hi i'm julie i'm the tech lead of the go
web team which works primarily on the go
package discovery site that lives at
pkg.go.dev
so the go package discovery site is a
place that helps go developers
find packages that might help them in
developing their own projects
and then also give them the information
they need to evaluate and decide if they
want to use these packages in their
[Music]
projects
everyone i'm rebecca and i work on the
go um
on go developer tooling so i the go team
actually supports a backend that
provides
idu-like features to most major editors
like vs code vim emacs and sublime
and we also maintain the go plugin for
vs code so i'll be talking about how
these developer tools can help you write
secure go code
excellent so we're going to start with a
question about
software reuse it's 2021 and whatever
you're doing you're always
reusing uh software now um
rebecca how does go provide dependency
management
so go code is typically grouped into
packages and then related packages can
be grouped into a larger module
and so a module is basically the unit of
dependency management and go
what happens is you can import libraries
that are provided by different modules
into your own module and the way that
you do that is by having a go.mod file
at the root of your project
and that god.mod file will specify each
module that you require and its version
that you required at so that way you'll
get reproducible builds in your project
and actually it's really simple to get
started with go modules all you really
need to do is run a command
go mod init inside of a directory and
it'll create this go.mod file for you
and then the go command will continue to
allow you to
like to download and upgrade and
downgrade your different dependencies
and also you can also get this feature
through your editor so you can
manage your modules through your editor
and you don't ever have to actually
manually edit that
mod file excellent um
you mentioned reproducible builds and
that is definitely something that um
are is dear to the heart of the security
team because
that means that even if something
changes in the outside world
uh a build of a gold module will always
be the same
independent and there's no way for
external uh compromises to
influence the application after it will
its
build has become reproducible now we
talked about
how go modules are managed but
the next question i think is for julie
how do i choose dependencies for my
project
that's yeah that's a really great
question um and i mentioned that
our my team works primarily on the go
package discovery site
um and it was actually built for the
purpose of helping developers choose
their third-party dependencies
so as we're building the site i would
say that we thought about surface and
information that belonged to three main
categories
and i would break these down into
popularity quality
and stability so a little bit about each
one
popularity i think is important because
it really just acts
as a social signal it tells you other
people are using this package
they've probably already done the work
for you to evaluate whether or not this
package is dependable
and if the author of the package decides
that they want to stop maintaining the
project
it's likely that one of the many people
who are depending on this project might
step up
and continue to maintain it when i say
quality
quality really just means looking at the
quality of the code itself
uh is this project well documented uh is
it well tested
um and does it generally just look like
quality go code that you feel
comfortable
including in your own project and i
think lastly stability um that's
the topic that's probably the most dear
to the security team's heart um
it means figuring out whether or not
this package is
reliable so security vulnerabilities is
definitely one of those features uh you
want to look at a package and see does
it have a history of security
vulnerabilities
but in general you're just really
looking at the package to see
is this something that i can not only
depend on today but months from now or
years from now
and looking at conventions like rebecca
mentioned um with go modules
whether or not the author follows
semantic versioning those are all some
things you want to look at when
considering
stability
[Music]
excellent um now the next question i
feel like
is um is definitely for me and katie
uh what are some new things coming to go
that will help
uh with end-to-end security um
one thing that i want to mention uh
myself is that we are building
a solution for vulnerability tracking
ego
so what we want to handle is when there
are already vulnerabilities that
are known in the outside world
we want to make sure that you can get to
know when those
vulnerabilities affect your application
or any of its dependencies
so there are two pieces to this one is
that we're going to maintain a first
party vulnerability database where
we track and collect all vulnerabilities
that have been disclosed publicly in
any go module that's publicly importable
and then we'll provide tooling
tentatively called
go audit that will use
the database access the database and
then report which
of the vulnerabilities that are known
affect your application
what what's interesting about it is that
it's going to use static analysis to
make sure that
it only shows you the ones that are
actually relevant to your application
so even if you do depend on a version of
a dependency that has a vulnerability
if there is no way for your application
to reach that code maybe because you're
not using that mode or plugin or setting
uh the goldit will not tell you about it
so that when you get a report
you know that you can prioritize fixing
it and uh spend the time
to uh to figure out what it is and and
why
and katie do you want to talk about
fuzzing yeah i would love to
um buzzing is something that's very near
and dear to my heart and really excited
about this coming really soon um fuzzing
is
uh like i said before it's a it's a kind
of automated testing
um that's a little bit different from
unit tests and it's something that
in the past has often really just been
leveraged by security researchers
and while that's really great we think
that every developer
who wants to use this tool can benefit
from it
it can help find bugs that your unit
tests might miss
and how it can do that is in its kind of
buzzing mode it actually can run
a fuzzing engine which generates inputs
for you
it can do some really smart things to
try to find new coverage and find new
crashes
um and in the default mode it's going to
work a lot like a unit test will
where you can provide the inputs and you
can provide what you
think it should do and then it'll report
to you if there's a problem
and there are existing tools out there
right now for fuzzing and go but
none that are built into the standard
distribution or part of the go tool
chain
and that's something that we think is
going to be really important to help
just the general user experience for go
developers
um and kind of provide a first-class
service with fuzzing so
i'm really excited about this and i'd
love to answer more questions about it
yeah i'm i'm also very excited about it
because uh indeed i used fuzzing as a
security researcher in the past
but uh it always felt weird that uh
fuzzing is considered this thing that
you prepare once you write the fuzzer
you run it once you find your back
bounces or not and then you throw it
away
yeah do you would imagine if unit tests
were something that
somebody just writes wants to find bugs
in your program and then throws them
away
after recording the bags um so we do
have a question
uh from alan about fuzzing
how long do you think it will be before
the new go fasting proposal uncovers
bugs in hardware i love that question
so thanks alan for asking um i think
it's gonna depend i mean
in my optimistic review um i
am hoping that people can start using
this tool really really soon
we're kind of on the cusp of being ready
for people to start beta testing it in
our development branch
um so people should definitely be
looking out for
upcoming announcements like that um i'll
definitely be posting on twitter so you
can watch
that but at that point as soon as people
are ready to start writing fuzz targets
they definitely should
and depending on how good the fuzzing
engine is which is what we're going to
be hopefully finding out during the beta
testing phase
the hope is that it can find bugs pretty
quickly
what we have right now is already using
what's called coverage guidance
meaning that it can actually see if
there's new code coverage during the
testing process
and kind of determine if that's an
interesting input or not
and if it is then it can kind of focus
on those inputs going forward
and you know get smarter as it runs and
so
um the hope is that as soon as people
start using it they're going to be able
to
find these bugs excellent
the next question from jamie is about
something
along the lines of sandboxing uh jamie
asks are there any plans to limit what
dependencies can be for example
declaring that a dependency package
can't make network calls or execute
child processes
it's something that's extremely
interesting to think about and it's
something that i always felt like
javascript could really do because
javascript already has
a full-fledged um sandboxing story or at
least it did until spectre happened and
realized that there isn't really a
security
boundary between things that run inside
the same process
so really uh i don't think we have any
plans
uh for uh for go for that because
remember that in go you can do things
like
um just use on save and access memory
directly
and although there used to be a safe
mode where the compiler would try to
disallow things that
look a little too that would allow you
to
mess with other dependencies we never
really trusted the safety of that
and it's been removed if i remember
correctly in go 112
or something like that our
recommendation is very much more to
use instead process sandboxing for
example the go playground
uses gvisor to just sandbox the entire
uh process and um and not smaller units
within the process
again spectra is uh really the the
problem with that kind of
um within process unboxing and uh
too long to go into details but spectra
is a vulnerability in the cpus
themselves
and truly a whole topic of itself
um i will stop talking about spectra
because i can totally just go on talking
about spectra kitty knows
instead i'll take the next question from
um
juliana hopefully so
how how to be sure that the public go
library that i use is secure
and doesn't contain back doors or
something else i feel like this is
something
uh your alley julie yeah
that's a really great question and i
think i mentioned like stability is
really one of the things that you want
to look for when you're thinking about a
third party package
so today i would say that probably the
best way to do it is actually just to
treat the code like it's your own go
code so
when you pull the code down you know run
the tests that are part of the
repository
hopefully there are tests there if not
it's a pretty strong signal for you
and maybe even write your own tests to
see if you can uncover things that
you're hoping to look for um but on our
end for the go team one of the things
i'm really excited about this year is
that
on the package discovery site we're
building out a virgin history timeline
so that when you're looking at packages
you can kind of look at
what the changes are from um version of
version for a package
um so for example is the author deleting
um
identifiers from version of version
that's probably a bad stability signal
um and then the felipe also actually
mentioned that the security team is
working on a go vulnerability database
and so the package discovery site is
going to be one of the places where we
can surface that information for you
so when you go and look at a package and
it has security vulnerability at the
most recent version
there'll be a little piece of
information there to say you know just
so you know
this has a security vulnerability be
careful when you're using this package
so i'm excited for that to come out this
year uh i also feel like it goes back to
what you are talking about
with social proof and um and popularity
because really
we're using software always involves um
a trust relationship
we will try we try to do our best to
make tools to
assess this trust relationship and to
minimize it but the trust relationship
is fundamentally there
uh and something that i think uh makes
the global ecosystem much better suited
for than others
to handle the trust relationship is that
there is a culture of limiting how many
dependencies you have
so there isn't a silver bullet to
make sure that there aren't uh backdoors
in a dependency
but the fewer dependencies you have the
the fewer
liabilities you have now we have another
question for uh about fuzzing from
stephen
uh will there be a way to seed fuzzing
or trace the seed profiles so that
errors can be repeated so how will i
know how to repeat the the failing test
yeah so um it's kind of two ways to
interpret that question so i guess i can
answer both um
as far as knowing whether or not um
so i guess the first part of the
question is you know if if in this flow
fuzzing generates an input that causes a
crasher
how do we know that that crasher is
actually fixed
and how can we run that crasher again in
the future and check that into our
repository as a unit test
what's really cool about this music ux
basically
um was a very intentional choice to try
to do this by default for the user so
if you were to run go test dash fuzz and
then specify your target
and it'll run and then if it finds a
crash it'll actually print out hey we
found a crash
we wrote it to test data for you uh and
here's the name of the file
and to run it again on that that
specific c
corpus in the opera you could actually
just
run go test dash run
fuzz whatever and not file or you can
just run go test and it'll just
include that as a normal unit test so
basically it can go from fuzzing to just
being a unit test without you needing to
do anything at all
um and i think that that's a really
important part of the ux
um and if you were to interpret the
question instead of like actually
running it the same way every single
time for debugging there is actually a
way to do that too that we're looking
into
where you can actually provide the seed
for randomness but that's probably not
something that most people
would benefit from that's more just for
debugging the actual fuzzing engine
i played with with the flow that kitty
is describing and i'm i was extremely
happy because
you know the fuzzer finds something and
usually with other fuzzers you have to
then
write more code to try to run the fuzzer
input into your program to figure out
how that happened and instead with this
you just run go test
and it fails again and then you try
fixing it and you're on good test and it
fails again let's be honest
uh and then you keep doing this a few
times and eventually the test passes and
you know that
uh that works and you did not write one
more line of
uh healer code or a boilerplate so yes
i'm extremely excited for this
now a question from peter um rebecca i
think this this one is
definitely for you uh and is what is the
best idea for
secure goal development i feel like more
than what the best one
uh we can talk about what they have in
common to you because i know that
there isn't that much difference in what
runs underneath right
yeah so basically the two most popular
editors um
our ivs for go development are vs code
and go
land and go land is a jet brains ide so
i won't really
be able to speak to that but i can speak
to vs code and bim and emacs and all the
other editors that
the go team does support um and so as i
mentioned earlier we have go
please which is the back end that
provides idu like features for all of
these editors and it
has all the same features across the
board and so you know linters that are
available through go please are
available in vs code them emacs all the
same
but since vs code is the most popular
editor
the go team also supports the vs code
plugin
for go directly and it does have a few
additional features that community
members built in
before the go team sort of took
ownership of it so it has a little bit
more linters that are just built in by
default
things like golang sea island are
available directly in the s code go
plugin
so that can be useful and help with
security
um but in general vs code has a few
features that are really nice for
security as well as that so right now
they're doing something called secure
trusted workspaces which basically means
that you can indicate that you trust a
workspace and that'll allow you to run
arbitrary commands in there and we've
just been in general careful about
a lot of the go extensions they run the
go command under the hood and so we've
been a bit more careful lately about
making sure that we
check that airport space is trusted
before we do that anybody paying
attention to the
security updates might have noticed that
that's actually something that's fairly
hard
in go we have this security model where
we consider looking at code and building
code
uh not the same as running it uh other
ecosystems just
don't have the distinction and that's
you know a design decision
but in go we guarantee that downloading
a dependency building it
opening it in vs code go is not going to
execute code from it
and that's something that we really like
for triaging
vulnerable code because it means we can
open random code from the internet
without being worried about
that code trying to run something in the
background on us
now we have another question uh that we
got before the session
that i feel like uh dovetails well on
that
um does go have a debugger and what are
upcoming new features for debugging
yeah absolutely so go has a debugger
called delve and it's had it for a long
time though i know a lot of people often
don't
actually they may not be aware that
gohan has a debugger but you can access
it through any uh
there are plugins basically for all
these editors like vs code
and vim etc um but there's a lot of new
stuff coming in this area so
actually the way that go please works
the ide back end
is that basically it speaks the language
server protocol which basically all
editors can speak it and the language
server provides these features and
that's how they communicate
so it's a very similar thing for
debuggers actually it's called dap it's
a
debug adapter protocol and so delve is
getting
basically what one big thing that the
tools team is doing
is working on adding depth natively to
delve
so basically this is going to be a
debugger after um
implementation directly in the debugger
and the
like it's actually it's going to be
coming out shortly
i think it's available right now in
experimental mode but i think it'll be
enabled in a preview version of the
extension by default pretty soon
and so you can try that out in ds code
go and what's really nice about that is
it's sort of previously this debug
adapter had been written
specific to each editor plugin just like
the same thing for the ide integrations
like what go please kind of solved
so basically now there's going to be a
go implementation of this protocol
and any editor can use it as well so
basically debugging should become a lot
easier for you soon
that's awesome i knew about the language
protocol this language support protocol
is that right
what does lsp stand for language server
protocol language server protocol yes
and i knew about that i didn't know that
there was an
equivalent one for debugging and that
sounds great because again
there was so much duplicated work
between each
editor and id having to integrate with
all of the tooling or even worse
revealable of the drilling
so that's excellent um we have
um we have another question from
steven about fuzzing so will fuzzing be
more than
just um type registries with candidate
values per type
what kind of smarts are in fuzzing and
i think steven here is probably asking
about the mutator i guess
what do you think yeah i'm actually not
sure what a type registry
is um but i can definitely talk about
which types will be supported and
kind of how the mutual work in that way
so um right now
in the basically the development branch
that we're working in
it's just supporting basic types like a
bite slice a string
um an end a u-wind float things like
that
um and all those things can be mutated
in the mutator
and spit out new inputs based on the
values in the corpus and in the future
we also want to be able to support more
types just generally speaking like an
ant slice for example
things like that but we also want to be
able to support struxx types in the
future
so um that doesn't necessarily mean
we're going to support
every single struct right away but what
we can do
at the beginning at least is to just
support um
structs that basically have an
implementation
of the um text marshalling or binary
marshalling
interface um and so what we can do is
then just mutate the bytes under the
hood
and then just um unmarshal it back into
the struct value before we run it
against the fuzz function
and that's something we hope to have as
well and more details on that
um as far as like how it works under the
hood and what kinds of things are going
to be supported
you can see better on the design draft
that's online um that's it
slash s slash draft dash design
i think it's draft buzzing dash design
um or you can just uh
google it should come up pretty quickly
i hear this google engine works pretty
well
now um talking we talked about stability
for for a second earlier
um what are some features on pkg.go.dab
that can help me evaluate if a project
is stable
yeah that's a great question um so on a
high level on the right hand side of
every package page you'll see this
little
detail section um and that'll tell you
if you're looking at the stable a stable
version
of a package um and so if the author is
following go module conventions
then a package is expected to be stable
once it's been tagged with the view 1.0
or higher release
um and then additionally if an author
decides to retract their package version
or the entire module has been deprecated
you'll see a bright yellow banner across
the site that tells you you know
you probably don't want to use this
package we also have some features on
our roadmap that are going to help
developers evaluate stability so i
mentioned earlier
about showing more about the package api
history
from version of version so that users
can see that the package api is going to
change across different versions
we're also planning to surface
information from the go vulnerability
database
and lastly also more information about
whether or not specific identifiers are
um deprecated within the api itself
um and we got another question that
i feel like is paired with this one um
why do go modules require
a semver semantic versioning because you
mentioned v0 v1
and uh maybe you can say a little more
about
what semantic versioning is and how it
plays into apis
yeah definitely um synthetic versioning
is basically just a convention
that is used um not just in go um but
specifically with go modules um it's a
way for the author to be able to
indicate
the uh i guess level of stability that
you can expect from this project
and so if it's v0 um then it's
uh expected that the author might be
causing um
changes in their api they might
potentially be deleting um an identifier
from version
version effectively this package is not
stable yet um and because it's v0 the
author is following the convention of
indicating to its users
this is not stable whereas once you get
to v1 or higher
then one something that you want to be
able to do is make sure that from
version to version you're not breaking
your users
so say i'm using a function foo in 1.5.2
i don't want to download 1.6 and then
all of a sudden the author deleted the
identifier and i can't use it anymore um
and that's also why go has
this um convention of using deprecations
and adding a deprecated comment
when an author doesn't want you to use
an identifier anymore
but um it should still be there in case
a user was depending on that in a
previous version
um and i think the last piece of this is
really just major versions
um and so if you have a change between
v1
and v2 and v3 um it's expected that it's
possible to have breaking changes
between different major versions
and so go actually has semantic import
versioning so
that the import path changes to indicate
this to users as well
yeah the um the point about multiple
major versions is i think something that
comes in very handy when you end up
depending on something that
depends on two things that depend on two
different major versions of the same
thing
this is usually called the diamond
diamond problem uh
and in go that problem uh is
just sold by the fact that you can you
can have
two different major versions of the same
module in the same
build and if they don't have the same
major version then they need to be
compatible
and if they're compatible you can just
use the most recent version
so if two things depend on the only one
we'll just make the
newest version and if a thing depends on
v1 and one v2 we'll just have them both
available
that's just one of the design bits of
modules that i always really liked
and you also answered part of one of the
questions that we got earlier that
is about the crypto libraries which is
how often
uh do you have to deprecate all their
crypto libraries and do these
deprecations break all their versions of
go
so there are two places where we have
crypto libraries
uh and for context uh go comes with a
complete set of cryptography libraries
including things like tls and encryption
and signatures
uh and um we do deprecations
we did a bunch of duplications in the
last few years partially because the
libraries are almost 10 years old
and we want to make sure that anything
that you find in these libraries is
something that
you would want to use and that is modern
enough that
this is not going to be a football
so we do deprecations but the
applications are just surfaced through
tooling
they will just for example show up in
your editor saying hey you're using this
thing that is deprecated and here's some
text that explains the location
and here's what you can use instead and
they
absolutely never break um go code
whether they are
in the standard library or in the golang
org x crypto repository because both of
them follow
the go backwards compatibility promise
and send their so make sure that
they're always backwards compatible uh
so we use the application instead to
communicate about things that we kind of
wish weren't there
but we're going to keep them there
because we don't want to break anybody
uh okay so our time is
running out so we had one last question
uh
which i think everybody can uh could
answer
what is one thing you would recommend
checking out for go uh katie do you want
to start
yeah so one thing i think that's worth
checking out is go.dev
this is something that julie can also
probably
care a lot about um but go.dev is going
to be kind of a
a new way to explore go in the past
everyone went to golang.org to read
about it but
god.dev has a lot of cool things like
case studies and
information about how it can be used and
so if you're an enterprise and you want
to look into adding go that's a really
good place to start
julie um yes go. it's very near and dear
to my heart so
i hope that everyone checks it out um
but i think one of the things that
i've really loved about building the go
package discovery site is
actually just discovering some really
amazing packages for my development
workflow
and some that we use all the time um is
static check which runs static analysis
on your code and it's caught tons of
bugs and made improvements to my code
um emperor am has helped me capture a
ton of
unused function parameters and results
in my code um
ms spell has helped me catch a lot of
commonly misspelled english words and so
those are some packages that i really
love and use all time and
recommend checking out yeah those are
excellent rebecca
yeah for sure static check is available
in your editor so
definitely use that but i would
recommend checking out the go playground
which is a sandbox where you can
basically play with go code
without having to have anything on your
computer and you can have you know
multiple files you can
use third-party dependencies in it it's
really awesome it's a really quick way
to just like write something
if you want just like a scratch project
wonderful
um so on my side something that i used
just a couple days ago is this package
called
air group that you can find in the
golden org x sync
module which allows you to run in
parallel a number of
goer keys and just when one of them hits
an error
all of them get cancelled and the error
gets returned at the end i find it just
such a nice way to build parallelization
into the programs
now this has been fun and we didn't get
to all of the questions but
we'll try to answer them in the dory and
if anybody has any other questions you
can always reach the go community and
the google team
on the golang nuts like in peanuts uh
mailing list
and on the go first slack thank you
everyone and have a great rest of the
[Music]
conference